on this Saturday night a seniors home in
BC the center of an outbreak
investigating the link between the
facility and a healthcare worker
infected with the new corona virus we
are in an extraordinary situation the
tough task of tracing where else the
worker may have been trapped with kovat
19 on a cruise ship if you're asking my
advice I say don't go the freight
warning to avoid this kind of travel
plus the call for mandatory paid sick
days during the health crisis an Iranian
family seeks refuge in Canada after
their son is killed in the Ukrainian
Airlines disaster and who is tulsi
gabbard how the lone female running in
the Democratic race is managing to stay
in the spotlight
global national would Robin Gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with developing news about
the spread of the new corona virus the
British Columbia government confirms an
outbreak at a Vancouver area long-term
care home for seniors to residents there
have tested positive for Kovan 19
tonight we are learning the woman who
was the first person in the country to
contract the virus through community
contact is a health care worker at the
facility and that worrisome situation is
sitting heavy with the provinces chief
medical health officer at this time I am
asking people to consider having virtual
gatherings to consider not coming
together particularly if you have people
in your gathering who are who are
elderly or more
the fatigue and the stress are setting
in the two patients at the seniors home
are among six new cases of Coppa 19
confirmed in BC today that brings the
number of confirmed cases in Canada to
at least 57 two of those BC cases
involve recent travel to Iran the other
two are people who are previously
passengers on the cruise ship that is
now quarantined off the coast of San
Francisco we'll have more on that in a
moment but first here's Michael Couture
on the efforts to prevent the virus from
spreading among the public it's a whole
community problem and you see it in
these three sets of cases today the six
new BC cases originated in different
places across the globe to our people
who recently traveled to Iran two were
previously passengers on the cruise ship
that is now quarantined off the coast of
San Francisco and the last pair are
perhaps most concerning as they are
elderly patients from a care home in
North Vancouver that's worrisome not
only because the mortality rate is
higher in older people but because those
two are connected to that first
community transmission which is said to
be a female employee of the Linn Valley
care center many people who work in care
homes work in many other settings as
well so there is an ongoing very
detailed investigation that will be done
which will include whether or not the
worker got kovat 19 from the Linn Valley
facility or perhaps another place she
may work and unknowingly transmitted it
to the to patients but what is clear
according to health officials is the
need to limit public gatherings where at
least keep your distance from others
while out and about that recommending it
for something as simple as religious
services or even large sporting events
like the rugby sevens championship being
held in Vancouver this weekend I brought
rubber gloves to go to the washroom and
I brought like little wipes and stuff
and I was a little bit
because I'm immune suppressant the
International Ice Hockey Federation has
taken it one step further cancelling the
Women's World Hockey Championship in
Halifax at the end of the month the
tournament will be played in Nova Scotia
next year instead the financial hit is
yet to be calculated but the emotional
toll of the crisis is clear particularly
if you have people in your gathering who
are who are elderly or more I went
through SARS I've been through Ebola
I've been through the the pandemic in
2009 and I just know how stressful it is
for our healthcare system for my
colleagues and for families and with the
outbreak widening in this country it
would seem that stress is only going to
get worse
Mike lacouture Global News as Mike
reported two of the cases in BC are
linked to a previous voyage on the Grand
Princess cruise ship that boat is
anchored off the coast of San Francisco
with 3,500 passengers and crew on board
including 237 Canadians at least 21
people on the ship have tested positive
for kovin 19 that's on top of the rising
number of cases across the US including
a popular destination for Canadians this
time of year Florida two people have now
died in that state as Abigail daemon
reports the number of test kits being
made available to Americans isn't
keeping up with the demand
minutes after passengers on board the
Grand Princess learned 21 people tested
positive for kovat 19 Global News spoke
to Canadians John and Assunta Garretson
I guess I'm just concerned now about
what's going to happen the former
Ontario cabinet minister and his wife
were set to fly back to Canada Saturday
that plans sidelined we just basically
put into it a lockdown situation to stay
in our staterooms and you know they're
providing us with with our meals and and
US President Donald Trump weighed in on
the 3500 people floating off the coast
of California including
237 Canadians but said he'd ultimately
let the experts decide as BC's Health
Minister issued the sternest warning
about traveling on cruises from a
Canadian official yet if you're asking
my advice I say don't go US Vice
President Mike Pence tasked with dealing
with the outbreak is in Florida to meet
with cruise ship executives that state
saw its first deaths from the virus the
first outside the West Coast this
administration is now scrambling to try
to make up for a very slow start to
reckon with the how fast this illness
would spread New York declared a state
of emergency with yet another spike in
cases the governor urging anyone placed
on a voluntary quarantine to adhere to
it violating those rules is first I
think disrespectful to members of the
community
it doesn't honor your responsibilities
as a citizen and you can be putting
people in danger
cancellations keep rolling in including
music festivals such as Texas is South
by Southwest the University of
Washington and Stanford have canceled
all in-person classes for the rest of
the quarter and a number of businesses
are asking employees to stay home
including tech giants on the west coast
abigail Beeman Global News Washington
we're watching two other cruise ships in
limbo tonight Egyptian authorities say a
ship with over a hundred and fifty
tourists on the nile river has been
quarantined after 45 people tested
positive for Cova 19 there are no
Canadians on board and Malaysia has
turned away a cruise ship carrying 2,000
passengers the cost of fortuna was also
denied port at a popular Thai resort
because of the presence of 64 Italians
on board if you do show symptoms after
returning home from abroad or have been
in contact with someone who may have
been exposed Health Canada has specific
guidelines it wants you to follow
you should isolate yourself immediately
call ahead to a health professional or
Public Health Authority for advice on
what to do be ready to describe your
symptoms and travel history health
authorities are also asking anyone who's
sick to stay home from work but not all
employers provide sick benefits that
puts workers in a tough spot when faced
with losing pay as Ross lorde reports
there are calls for new measures to
protect employees who are ill and the
people they work with taking sick days
is it easy for Kim Stewart she's a real
estate agent face to face contact with
customers is crucial even when she's not
feeling well
and I've gone out there wrapped up in a
scarf I've said like don't touch me I've
tried not to touch door handles with my
hands or anything and I've been out
there working while I was ill the last
thing she'd ever wanted to do is spread
a deadly virus but it's tough to follow
health authorities advice and stay home
if she develops flu-like symptoms that
could turn out to be covered 19 many
others face a similar predicament
because taking a sick day means losing
salary our entire livelihood is based
upon our ability to work so like if we
can't get to work then we can't pay rent
we don't get paid if we're sick concerns
are growing across Canada that choosing
between getting paid and going into
isolation could allow the virus to
spread b/c premier John Horgan is urging
employers to be generous with sick time
if they don't have sick leave benefits
for their employees and these
circumstances I think they might want to
consider that as a solid investment and
not just their employees but their
business in Nova Scotia and in Ontario
there are also calls for mandatory paid
sick days the Nova Scotia government
says it will consider removing a
requirement for doctors notes at least
for government workers even if for the
short term that we actually suspend that
practice some small businesses disagree
there are other employers that look at
it from saying I need some controls on
whether people are going to be off sick
and making sure that it's a legitimate
illness tough decisions are looming
health authorities expect the
coronavirus responsible for Cova 19 to
spread
even to areas like Atlantic Canada that
currently don't have any cases if and
when it does it could put Kim Stewart
and many others in an unenviable
position
Ross Lord Global News Halifax Italy's
government is putting Milan and several
regions nearby into lockdown in a bid to
contain the outbreak starting today
nobody can enter or exit those areas the
Pope cancelled all public appearances
going forward and will instead stream
services on the Internet also today the
leader of Italy's Democratic Party
confirmed he has Cova 19:00 via Facebook
there has been a big jump in cases in
Italy which continues to record the
highest deaths per day in the world
Italy's Civil Protection Agency confirms
another 36 people died in just 24 hours
and another 1,000 people were infected
numbers have spiked in Iran where more
than a thousand new cases were reported
by the country's health ministry which
fears the number of cases could be much
higher another 21 people died in Iran
today bringing the death toll to 145 one
of those deaths was a Conservative MP
it's another sign the virus is spreading
within state institutions Iran's deputy
Health Minister and another member of
parliament have contracted Kovan 19
frantic rescue efforts are underway in
southeastern China where a hotel used to
quarantine people infected with Cova 19
collapsed the hotel was being used to
isolate and monitor people arriving from
regions hardest hit by the new
coronavirus so far at least 43 and the
70 people trapped under the rubble have
been rescued
we know you have lots of questions about
this virus and we want to help answer
them send an email to your questions at
global news dot CA and our geoff sample
will consult experts to find the answers
you'll also find extensive information
on our website we have a special page
dedicated entirely to the new corona
virus that's a global news dot CA /
corona virus coming up while the family
of an Iranian man killed
Ukrainian Airlines tragedy is looking
for help in Canada
a fresh flare-up in tension today as
more migrants tried to cross into Greece
from Turkey police used tear gas to
drive them back and there are reports
some were stripped beaten and sent back
across the border thousands of migrants
have been trying to enter through
Greece's border after turkey announced
it would no longer stop them crossing
over to countries in the EU the family
of an Iranian passenger killed on flight
752 is now looking for help here in
Canada their son was on his way to
Edmonton to study at the University of
Alberta when the Ukrainian Airlines
plane was shot down now his family
members say they've been threatened in
their home country for speaking out
about his death and they're looking for
refugee status here
Global's quin Ola reports the images are
hard to forget
flight 752 shot down shortly after
takeoff from Turan Airport for a mere
Husein saya Dena's mother she remembers
the hours before her son saying goodbye
before boarding the flight it was very
hard to say goodbyes he went for the
gate and waved he told his that several
times please take care of mom his family
now shattered
they took somebody from me who was my
everything all my hopes all my dreams
along with the heartache saya Dena's
family says they've been targeted and
threatened by Iran's Revolutionary Guard
they say they were under surveillance
for talking about their loved one and
claiming despite what Iranian officials
have said the missile attack was no
accident it started right after his
death I lost my most precious thing the
regime tells me not to speak up not to
say anything the students parents
brother and aunt
fled to Turkey leaving everything behind
homes cars all their belongings our
voice has been suffocated we can't say
anything so I wanted to share those
stories with everybody else now they're
asking for help
we're hoping that the Canadian
government would help us demand justice
and say if they are forced to go home
they fear they will be arrested and
killed for their son they say they'll
never stop telling his story I want the
whole world to know there was a boy
named Amir was saying and I'm rewarding
to know that is gone
kwinto ler Global News Edmonton
gabbard's
gamble still ahead a presidential
hopeful goes all-in with the odds
against her America's largest
presidential primary field has been
narrowed down to three but only two will
spar on the stage during this month
democratic debate the two male
candidates both in their 70s the third
candidate a 37 old woman hasn't
qualified for a debate in 2020 but as
Reggie Cecchini explains that hasn't
stopped Tulsi Gabbard from pulling the
punches she may not have the name
recognition of her competitors but Tulsi
Gabbard a Democratic presidential
hopeful has stamina and apparently
staying power again I I I can't do the
math on any of that and I'm a pollster
but I can't do the math on any of that
so I asked you to join me
Gabbard Hawaii representative entered
the Democratic race on January 11th 2019
and in that time she's managed to find
herself both out of and right in the
spotlight
we've been dealing with basic total
blackout throughout this entire campaign
the Iraq war veteran with only two
pledged delegates has failed in all
primary contests so far and barely
qualified for early debates as much as
they have tried to erase us from this
election we stand strong Gabbard
struggles are self-inflicted at times
she sounded more like President Trump
than a Democrat and it is the
Constitution that provides that our
foreign policy is set by the president
United States not by unelected
bureaucrats and acted as a presidential
supporter not voting YES on impeachment
we could end up with a Republican House
Republican Senate
Republic administration she's a target
for her own party accused of being an
apologist for Syria's leader and is a
fan favorite of bots on social media
leading to this failed swipe I think
they've got their eye on somebody who's
currently in the Democratic primary and
are grooming her to be the third party
candidate she's a favorite of the
Russians Hillary Clinton is is labeling
me as a foreign agent and a traitor but
if running on a series of controversy is
the plan pollsters say it isn't working
I have no clue what the rationale is for
staying in this race and with odds of a
win matching her polling at one in 100
Tulsi Gabbard may be the only one still
willing to place that bet
Reggie Cecchini Global News Washington
up next crime beat Global News digs into
the death of an Alberta girl
tonight marks the debut of a new series
on global television called crime beat
it will examine some of Canada's darkest
crimes and the impact they've had on our
society the first episode features a
tragedy involving a young Calgary girl
Global's Nancy Hicks explains why she
wanted to begin the series with the
story of Myka Jordan in my house I have
a bulletin board where I put up photos
of the people I love in the top left
corner there's a picture of the most
beautiful little girl you can see she's
bright playful smart innocent the girl
in the picture is Mika Jordan she's a
part of my heart but I never got to meet
her this was a girl that I honestly
don't think had the capability to have a
bad day I've been a crime reporter for
more than two decades I cover dark
subject matter day in and day out as a
journalist I try to make sense of these
crimes but some are so horrific they're
simply beyond comprehension
[Applause]
on November 13th 2011 Mika Jordan was
rushed to hospital she died the
following day could a six-year-old girl
beat that badly injured from a fall down
the stairs
just days after losing their daughter
I met Micah's mother and stepfather Kyla
and Bryan Woodhouse the first time we
got to see her was when we finally
realized how serious of a situation it
actually was I was extremely shocked
that you're part of it is I am still in
shock there's still part of me that that
wants her to come walking through that
door I learned this was a split family
Mika and her little brother spent half
their time with them and the other half
of their time with Spencer Jordan and
Marie Magoon their biological dad and
stepmother the weekend Mika was rushed
to hospital the two kids were supposed
to be at their mom
instead their father and stepmother kept
them there were only two people with
access to Mika
that fateful day I decided to try to
speak with them we're just hoping we
could talk to you about the death of
Mika Jordan the case took many twists
and turns making it difficult to share
the complete story in a typical two
minute news report that was the starting
point of the crime beat podcast a
platform where as a journalist I could
give a full perspective on the impact of
this case Micah's mom and stepdad do
everything they can to keep Micah's
memory alive and now her story is being
shared with a wider audience on our new
global TV series crime beat Bryan had
always said you know the she had the
power to change the world one day and
unfortunately the loss of her life had
to be the way that she did it
Nancy Hicks global news you can watch
maker Jordans story on the debut of
crime beat tonight on Global TV and that
is global national for this Saturday I'm
Robin Gill tonight your Canada is the
wild Pacific trail in you clueless BC
email your pictures to viewers at global
national calm and a reminder it's time
to spring forward for daylight saving
time so set your clocks ahead one hour
before you go to bed it'll be the last
time in Yukon where daylight saving is
becoming permanent thank you for
watching have a great night
[Music]